das ist Katrin und vor einem Jahr hatte
sie ein großes Ziel ihr eigenes Gemüse
anbauen und ihrer Familie richtig gutes
Essen auftischen am Anfang hat sie oft
gehört dass sie den Plan eigentlich
knicken kann weil der Boden hinter ihrem
Haus nicht nur voller Steine war sondern
auch noch vom Bau so verdichtet dass
dort nicht mal mehr Gras wuchs aber
katrin hat sich für meinen Onlinekurs
Gemüsegarten starten angemeldet dann hat
sie mit kompostbeten den miesen Boden
aufgepeppt und diese unfassbar coole
Vogelscheuche aufgestellt und es wäre so
leicht gewesen den Kopf einfach in den
Sand zu stecken und gar nicht erst
anzufangen mit dem Gärtnern aber dann
wäre dieser unglaubliche Garten nie
entstanden es ist nicht der Wahnsinn was
man ohne Erfahrung innerhalb von ein
paar Monaten schaffen kann wenn Ihr auch
Lust habt in meinem gemüsegartenstenkurs
mit dabei zu sein dann schaut auf meinem
Profil vorbei zurzeit läuft nämlich eine
saftige Rabattaktion